People call me old and smelly, but apparently
that’s not something scientists want to
recreate.
Their loss.
Hey there nosy viewers, Jules here for Dnews!
Have you ever wondered what the world smelled
like centuries ago?
Everything probably smelled a little different,
and some smells just aren’t around anymore.
For example, what about flowers that have
long since gone extinct?
It’s a shame we’ll never get to know their
scent.
Or will we?
Well, scientists are actually working on unearthing
old frozen flowers from the Ice Age, but to
understand how those smells are coming back,
you need to understand what a fragrance, or
smell, is.
Take something like a rose.
For a perfume or a body wash to contain the
scent, roses are grown and picked and then
their essential oils are extracted, which
contain aroma compounds.
These are chemical molecules that bind to
receptors in our noses.
The receptors then send signals to our brains,
which interpret the compounds as smells.
In fact, you can extract these compounds yourself
at home by running steam through aromatic
plants, then collecting and cooling the steam.
For a long time, perfume makers would use
this process, but it has huge problems, mainly
that it depends entirely on crop yield, which
can vary year to year, and be relatively unpredictable,
and in some cases, unreasonably expensive.
So instead, scientists have developed a new
method of creating smells, almost from scratch.
See, the reasons plants have any smell at
all is because their DNA contains genetic
code that tells it to use enzymes to create
specific types of aromatic chemicals, which
are used to attract pollinating insects.
In roses these chemicals include citronellol,
geraniol, nerol, farnnesol, linalool, eugenol,
and rose oxide.
It’s a complex smell.
But the fact is, the rest of the rose and
it’s genetic coding doesn’t really matter
for perfumeries; they don’t need the complete
list, they just need the part that makes smells.
So, what scientists have done is take yeast,
yes, the one from beer and bread, and genetically
engineer it.
Normally, yeast consumes sugars, and farts
out alcohol and carbon dioxide in a process
known as “fermentation”.
But this yeast’s DNA is altered to mimic
the mechanisms in plants that create aromatic
compounds.
So, instead, the yeast eats fatty acids and
farts out good-smelling chemicals.
That’s a huge deal for scent creation, because
it leads to a more consistent, cheaper and
more efficient product.
But what is even cooler, is looking at recreating
scents where we may not have the living specimen,
but we do have its DNA.
That’s what a company called Ginko Bioworks
is trying to do, using extinct plants that
may be difficult or impossible to regrow,
altering yeast to match these extinct DNA
sequences.
Unfortunately, this is a really lucrative
and proprietary area, so they haven’t released
exactly how they’re genetically altering
the yeast in question.
But the science behind the concept is decades
old and has been used more and more in recent
years as an alternative to the traditional
method.
Soon, you might just be able to buy a perfume
that smells like flowers from another time.
We can’t do DNews episodes without our sponsors.
Thanks to Kay Jewelers for sponsoring this
episode.
For 100 years, every kiss begins with K.
So we can find out what extinct flowers smell
like but what about space?
What does space smell like?
You can find out by watching this video right
here.
And what's your favorite smell?
Let us know down below in the comments and
don't forget to subscribe and keep coming
back here for more DNews everyday.